more function visualizations so let's
say you have a function it's got a
single input T and then it outputs a
vector and the vector is going to depend
on T so the X component will be T times
the cosine of T and then the Y component
will be T times the sine of T this is
what's called a parametric function and
I should maybe say one parameter
parametric function one parameter and
parameter is just kind of a fancy word
for input parameter so in this case T is
our single parameter and what makes it a
parametric function is that we think
about it as drawing a curve and its
output is multi-dimensional so you might
think when you visualize something like
this oh it's got you know a single input
and it's got a two-dimensional output
let's graph it you know put those three
numbers together and plot them but what
turns out to be even better is to look
just in the output space so in this case
the output space is two-dimensional so
I'll go ahead and draw a coordinate
plane here and let's just evaluate this
function at a couple different points
and see what it looks like okay so I
might maybe the easiest place to
evaluate it would be 0 so f of 0 is
equal to and then in both cases it'll be
0 times something so 0 times cosine of 0
is just 0 and then 0 times sine of 0 is
also just 0 so that input corresponds to
the output you could think of it as a
vector that's infinitely small or just
the point at the origin however you want
to go about it so let's take a different
point just to see what else could happen
and I'm going to choose PI halves of
course the reason I'm choosing PI halves
of all numbers is that it's something I
know how to take the sine and the cosine
of so T is PI halves cosine of PI halves
then you start thinking okay what's the
cosine of PI halves what's the sine of
PI halves and maybe you go off and draw
a little unit circle while you're
writing things out oops so the problem
with talking while writing sign of PI
halves and you know it's if you go off
and scribble that little unit circle you
say PI halves is going to bring us a
quarter of the way around over here and
cosine of PI halves is measuring the X
component of that so that just cancels
out to zero and then sine of PI halves
is the Y component of that so that ends
up equaling one which means that the
vector as a whole is going to be zero
for the X component and then PI halves
for the Y component and what that would
look like you know the Y component of PI
halves it's about one point seven up
there and there's no X component so you
might get a vector like this and if you
imagine doing this at all the different
input points you might get a bunch of
different vectors off doing different
things and if you were to draw it you
don't want to just draw the arrows
themselves because that'll clutter
things up a whole bunch so we just want
to trace the points they correspond to
the output the tips of each vector and
what I'll do here I'll show a little
animation let me just clear the board a
bit an animation where I'll let T range
between zero and ten so let's write that
down so the value T is going to start at
zero and then it's go to 10 it's going
to go to 10 and we'll just see what
values what vectors does that output and
what curve does the tip of that vector
trace out so it goes all of the values
just kind of ranging zero to ten and you
end up getting this spiral shape and you
can maybe think about why this cosine of
T sine of T scaled by the value T itself
would give you this spiral but what it
means is that when you you know we saw
that zero goes here evidently it's the
case that ten outputs here and a
disadvantage of drawing things like this
you're not quite sure of what the what
the interim values are you know you
could kind of guess maybe one
go somewhere here to go somewhere here
and kind of hoping that they're evenly
spaced as you move along but you don't
get that information you lose the input
information you get the shape of the
curve and if you just want you know an
analytical way of describing curves you
find some parametric function that does
it and you don't really care about the
rate but just to show where it might
matter
oh I'll animate the same thing again
another function that draws the same
curve but it starts going really quickly
and then it slows down as you go on so
that function is not quite the T cosine
T et sine of T though I originally had
written and in fact it would mean that
let's just erase these guys when it
starts slowly you could interpret that
as saying okay maybe well actually it
started quickly didn't it so one would
be really far off here and then two it
could have zipped along here then three
you know still going really fast and
then maybe by the time you get to the
end it's just going very slowly just
kind of seven is here it is here and
it's hardly making any progress before
it gets to ten so you can have two
different functions draw the same curve
and the fancy word here is parameterize
so functions will parameterize a curve
if when you draw just in the output
space you get that curve and in the next
video I'll show how you can have
functions with a two-dimensional input
and a three-dimensional output draw
surfaces in three-dimensional space